non alors j'ai plus particulièrement
parler de blanche neige et les sept
nains bien sûr parce que pour moi le
terme n'est pas péjoratif dans la mesure
où faut appeler un chat un chat et je
trouve que créature par contre là ça me
gêne ça me pose problème c'est disney a
proposé on va placer en attendant c'est
de remplacer les nains par des créatures
magiques qu'on encore non identifié et
puis moi je trouve que dans ce dessin
animé les nains ils sont c des personnes
bienveillantes ils sont ils sont mignons
s'attache à eux et si vraiment on veut
se poser des questions sur le l'image
des personnes de petite taille dans la
télé on ferait mieux de d'aller voir
surtout sur d'autres programmes comme
comme je voyage en brouillard boyard ou
là pour moi l'image des personnes de
petite taille jeudi voir dès demain est
complètement dévalorisé trouve que ces
grades en forme après bien sûr pourquoi
pourquoi parce qu'en fait moi quand les
propos négatifs que j'ai eu à mon
encontre à l'école elle ne comparaît pas
on n'a jamais appelé simple et aux
grincheux ouais c'est pas cher tout
passe par tous et parce que je trouve
que l'utiliser des personnes de petite
taille pour courir à idées avec des clés
et courir après des lions ce sans parler
des tyloo pardon c'est le catch est
ouais c'est ça
c'est ça ma same as well as tu parles
ccd comme des bêtes et j'aime pas ça
donne en europe pour discuter avec
passe-partout andré il est extrêmement
évalué dans ce qu'il fait oui bah il
parle pas parce qu'il fait toutes les
versions internationales donc pour ce
faire comprendre voilà il mûri
fonctionnalités geste qu'il ne parle pas
pour ça quoique cette année il ya eu
quand même une petite évolution dans les
choses mais sont extrêmement épanouie
justement ça mais ça permet de mettre en
valeur tous types de personnes à la
télévision dans un jeu comme dans un
conte de fées et là par exemple on
critique un conte de fées qui a été
créée en 1830 de blanche-neige et les
siens le bisou sans consentement
rappelez vous quand même comment ça se
termine ils se marièrent il est urgent
beaucoup d'enfants donc finalement c'est
très très positif et d'ailleurs chez
disney les héros en sons des bruits mais
ce sont des princesses ont été
incroyables 7e rencontre est ce que tu
viens de dire est que je n 2 mais en
revanche oui il faudrait peut-être en
tout cas modifier la perception que ça
peut envoyer à nos enfants aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que la compréhension du
monde on est dans un société en ce
moment où on essaie de gommer le genre
bon là j'ai dit c'est moi c'est par les
mains après oui effectivement j'ai pas
concernés par le sujet donc je me rends
pas compte mais effectivement sur fois
les sept nains dans disney dans blanche
neige ça me dérange pas parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un peu la conscience un
côté dérangeant c'est la position de la
femme en fait mais c'est juste un moment
donné elle passe pour une énorme hawkish
c'est à dire du tout non a pas du tout
un jeu bon viendra dans ma tente juste
la chaussure onirique un jour mon prince
viendra 7
en fait que le prince viennent pour être
épanoui son épanouissement personnel
passe par le fait de passer le balai
pour cette mecque a bandé
et ça c'était les télés romy disney il
serait peut-être temps
après dans les années 90 on a eu
des guerres mullan carrément qui se
traduit travestie en homme pour être
intégrés à l'armée chinoise qui se coupe
les cheveux dans un but d'émancipation
précédent pour que justement la femme
commencent à s'émanciper mais bon les
dessins animés disney c'est paris
suivent la société issue la société faut
arrêter de regarder dans le rétroviseur
vous êtes toujours en train de vouloir
écrire l'histoire a essayé d'écrire
l'avenir c'est déjà plus intéressant
quand même c'est pas parce que
évidemment oui
[Applaudissements]
qu'à l'image on puisse est positive des
7 nains il est chasseur et plus à se
plaindre d'avoir tué la maman de bambi
ou les belles mères qui ont une image
déplorable en tout lisse ne et pourra
limite descendent dans la rue pour aller
les foires et aideront
les femmes c'est exactement la même
chose mais c'était vous le même sac une
telle émission
qui s'annonce et des objets c'est tout
le secteur qui finissent par se mettre
des coups de pancartes où les jeunes sur
ce sujet
[Applaudissements]
regardez un cassage de port cartier
figurez-vous qu'en 2020 tout de même
disney a mis des avertissements sur
plusieurs de ses films pour prévenir
justement les téléspectateurs autre
phrase aussi plutôt disney donc je cite
plutôt que de supprimer ce contenu nous
tenons à reconnaître son influence
néfaste afin de ne pas répéter les mêmes
erreurs disney diffusent des messages
d'excusés à un mea culpa une
responsabilité en disant peut-être qu'on
véhicule décrit chez dans nos films
minces en excuses et on ne va plus se
reproduire mais ça c'est pas du tout
d'accord avec ça c'est que voilà pour
moi il ne faut pas les réécrire pour la
bonne raison que je pense que dans le
cas des personnes de petite taille elles
ne sont en aucun cas des screaming et je
pense que les les premiers pères et les
premiers concernés voilà c'est la
perception qu'on peut avoir et je sais
que moi à titre d' éducation quand j'ai
regardé le disney est un enfant je n'ai
pas développé aucun stéréotype que ça
pourrait personnes de petite taille ou
pour d'autres donc que j'ai eu aucun
problème d'identification et moi par
exemple je sais qu'ils aient eu aussi
une polémique sur le livre de la jungle
qui avait simulé voilà le roi louis il y
avait été évoqué que c'était un gamin
caractère raciste et honnêtement au
moins trois personnes de couleur je me
suis pas du tout senti discriminer n'y
ait ni quoi que ce soit et je pense que
c'est en grandissant c'est les
mentalités adultes qui nourrissent un
petit peu le débat alors que faut que ça
reste ça restait aux enfants je pense
que
vendéen des enfants en bas âge voilà où
très très jeune n'ont pas ce genre de
débat ils sont vraiment d'en vivre
ensemble et dans le nous faire marrer
mathias la nature je vais vous faire
marrer
ayrault mais maintient ses réponses sur
un point s'il ya toute cette nouvelle
génération de princesses de répondre
cette princesse au caractère bien trempé
rebelles qui porte bien son nom la reine
des neiges dans son royaume darren dell
qui a fait preuve de courage on en
change dans une éventuelle dimension où
les scénaristes ont pris conscience est
vrai de toute cette dévotion c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les princesses
n'attendent plus sagement que le prince
charmant verrait une les délivre
heureusement non mais c'est pas ça oui
bah non enfin c'est bah oui ben non
alors oui ou non
non non
votre médecin sans se dire qu'on peut
plus dire blanche neige et les sept
nains mais non racistes neiges et sept
seniors à croissance négative enfin ça
n'a pas de sens moi je pense que c'est
pas en récrivant et disney qu'on va
faire évoluer les moeurs je veux dire je
pense pas que les violeurs soit des
violeurs ce qu'elles sont trop regarder
la belle au bois dormant ou
blanche-neige et je pense pas que les
rasoirs atys qu'ils ont trop regarder
peter pan mois plus tard pense un dessin
animé qui a bercé mon enfance j'ai
toujours vu une ode intemporel où
pouvoir libérateur de l'imagination et
les hindous vous en dire que non avoir à
m'en une ode intemporel à quoi lui
redonner des relations au pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
oui élan même dire que non apparemment
ça des véhicules des idées racistes
alors que moi enfin peter pan j'ai
regardé mille et une fois je suis très
loin d'être rasées c'est comme les gens
qui sont là à dire oui en fait assez
rare en ces racistes a compris moi ce
qu'apparemment c'est vécu des desiderata
sur les ambiant dame et
le compenser ce qui sombra consentante
angers dire qu'elle est détraqué valais
va chercher à savoir si dans un dessin
animé destiné aux enfants les princesses
qui sont des personnages fictifs sont
vraiment qu'on s'entende corps étant
passé leur prince enfin je veux dire
enfin voilà faut sophie vous faites
partie de ces détraqués non
non mais c'est vrai que alors détraqué
peut-être pas mais il ya un moment donné
et moi je suis pas féministe ange pas à
brûler mon soutien-gorge fait plateaux
de télévision 'cependant n'hésitez pas
ils s'embrassent et les gorges
jean-michel non mais en revanche je
trouve que ça véhicule et pour les
petites filles et moi je suis
effectivement pour gommer les gens et je
trouve que disney a pratiquement tu sais
où disney s'excuse c'est qu'il ya eu une
erreur humaine une horreur de procéder
et c'est pas une époque on a attendu
très longtemps pour que la femme prenne
enfin sa place dans les dessins animés
disney ce soutien est ce que vous aimez
les enfants qui regardent ça ils pensent
pas à tous en même de minorités
d'égalité ses terrasses et des enfants
mais justement sont insouciants mais
juste donc je trouve que dans la
construction imaginaire sa cellule
adulte il pensé à ça va pas du tout au
contraire l'enfant se construit dans ces
inconscients et dans son imaginaire et
je trouve que quand il regarde quelque
chose comme ça qui dit voile mais comme
les barbies ostroff l'honneur alors
j'estime seront jamais d'accord sur ce
sujet dean et moi pour j'ai décroché un
crucifix pour moi ça divise plus que ça
ne fédère en quelque sorte et je pense
que voilà à vouloir dire telle
communauté stigmatiser telle communauté
est pointé je trouve qu alors on met le
doigt il ya beaucoup trop de en inde en
insistant ça divise plus que ça
veut dire
[Applaudissements]